there's survival as an enterprise which
is typically a financial cash flow
kind of an issue and then there's the
survival of a brand we had a dream
that we could really bring humanity back
to air travel i thought oh my gosh here
we have
really stubbed our toe on our most
fundamental proposition we're just like
everyone else
[Music]
so on valentine's day 2007
jetblue had an event that marks our
history and we hate
to have to keep revisiting but we
stranded a bunch of passengers on the
tarmac
at jfk
a storm came in that was freezing rain
and actually what happened was the tires
of the
aircraft froze to the tarmac
and the planes couldn't be moved so
planes were landing
but no planes could take off the runways
were like glass
and so we were unable to get buses out
to get people off of the planes
and that meant people were stranded for
seven eight nine hours
on planes within the terminal crowds
were building up and getting more and
more anxious and boisterous our general
counsel
went down and i remember him telling me
that he had to stand up on the counters
with a bull or
to try to settle people down i do know
that it takes a long time to rebuild a
schedule once you've grounded planes
once planes have built up in a certain
area it takes time to get them dispersed
to get your passengers out again
so it took several days to rebuild the
schedule
[Music]
at this time i was the lead director i
was not in town
at that point in time and couldn't have
gotten into town
so i heard about it and was brought in
by
telephone to talk to people and was
quite concerned about it
david nielsen who founded the airline
was apoplectic
and he wanted to fix it and make sure
that it never happened again
he then proceeded to go on all of the
talk shows and apologize
there were several of us on the board
that thought gosh
we're no worse than anybody else we just
happen to be a large carrier at jfk we
happen to be the hometown airline
and um i remember pulling him aside and
saying david you know enough apology
but he felt so bad that he went ahead
and did that
and i think he was right i think he
actually helped
restore the brand
[Music]
i think the immediate role of the board
is to make sure that we solve the
problem
on the ground beyond that we have to ask
the question is this something that
could happen
again so the board decided fairly early
on to bring in an outside consultant
to go through all of our systems top to
bottom we set up this internal team
of 100 people from all walks to look at
irops
irops are irregular operations and
they're
typically triggered by weather events
but i think what we found
in doing our own analysis of irops
was that we could do better at
communications and scheduling
the nuts and bolts of running the
airline the second thing is
when we brought in outsiders they also
said hey there's some things where
jetblue needs to grow up
so those weren't any of the things that
caused the problem they just said you
know if something else happens
again and you have not addressed some of
these problems it could get worse
for you what happened at that time
exposed several vulnerabilities that
would have developed into future
problems and we just really felt like
we're at an age and stage
now that we actually need to address
those and we didn't have confidence that
david
would be the best person to address them
so we did what any board of directors
has to do
is choose the ceo of the company david
was not removed because of the
valentine's day storm
in fact all it did was expose some
vulnerabilities we
had and when we did the internal review
and an external review we really thought
it was time to make a change
i think a lot of people thought it might
be over for jetblue we had so much
negative press
but i think david's sincere apology i
think our customer bill of rights i
think the
changes we made to handling irops to
addressing
the overall situation with growing an
airline
rapidly i think we quickly recovered our
brand
so the major takeaways for me are to
communicate you almost
can't over communicate the second one is
there's an impact of any of these kinds
of events on your brand
we had to really think about you know
how do we make sure that customers trust
us again
to me the most important thing for
managers is to remain
calm to listen to be thoughtful not to
lose it not to be frantic
you need to deal it with it seriously
these are important events
but how you manage them how you behave
will really be recalled long after the
event